Wow, thank you...
everybody
Relieved -- and finally free.
After hours hiding in toilet stalls, and under
desks ...
We just closed the doors and then gunshots
were just being sprayed all over.
From the top.
I think they went to the top floor and then
they started spraying bullets.
Just when I reached the ground floor, I saw
a woman get shot and then that`s when I took
the stairs back to the first floor.
And then someone locked me outside because
I am not from their office and then we went
to the washrooms, we were like seven people
in the same washroom.
From outside the hotel, a friend tried to
give reassurances by cellphone during the
12 hour ordeal.
So I had to keep telling her `just wait, help
is on the way, they are almost there, they
are almost there`.
And then at one point she was like `please
tell me I am getting out of here alive` and
then it was just like my breaking point.
CCTV showed the gunmen entering the hotel
complex before the attack.
Within hours - Somali-based terrorist group
Al Shabaab had claimed responsibility.
The morning after the attack Kenya's president
gave a defiant televised address, confirming
the siege was over - and that all the Islamists
involved had been eliminated.
We have shown Kenyans and the world we are
are ready to deal with any threat to our nation.
But many Kenyans are sceptical at the government's
ability to protect them.
We are blaming our internal security staff
because how did these people get into our
country and we have all of our security around.
This latest deadly assault in Nairobi shows
the Al quaeda linked group remains a force
for
the Kenyan
government
to reckon with.